well the bloggers criticized me for
reviewing the place like a blogger so
that's my answer them is oh you know if
you're going to do that fine but you
know that's that's the way bloggers work
anyways but generally what I would say
my answer would be what I just said hey
the place is impossible to get into be
it had been open for five weeks already
see the menus not going to change very
much and it was the same thing remember
when I reviewed masa the second time I
went back it was like you know what am I
doing here but I mean yeah it's fine but
it's it's the same food anyway so that
was that was you know I made the
decision all right up right now and it
was glowing al Chang you know I'm on
record as enjoying his food and again
this is a highly subjective business and
his last restaurant momofuku Sam I gave
three stars to for what that's worth
this food was of a higher caliber five
stars no sorry four stars there you go
possibly but again my argument is when I
just gave you know I don't think me
going back first of all I don't know if
I gonna get in right so if i go back two
months hints I don't know that it's
going to change very much now if it was
a Clutton I said all this in the review
and yeah this is Chang's whole thing is
that he's aunt these are not he's doing
things in an untraditional way at least
for this city this is sort of a non
restaurant restaurant and you know I I
chose to review it that way now if his
menus changing all the time and he's got
millions of dishes i hope the whole
point of going back is too so that you
can you don't have the same dish again
and again the whole point of going back
is to sample the entire menu now if
you've gone once and you've sampled the
menu there you have it now many bloggers
go to large restaurants with huge menus
and they they have one sitting and they
friends eat some stuff and maybe they
don't need everything and they blog away
so fine but you know I think in this
particular case I don't think I needed
to go fast